you know I was thinking about Gary
yesterday and I I mean you know first of
all I don't even know why you wanted to
volunteer for that parks record the
parks and recreation I said this guy
I must not bust his balls enough because
he's got too much free time he coaches
he's on the board of the record he
should be exhausted like I would have
not a free minute to be on any board I
just don't have it coach I coach I don't
have a free second like aren't are you
stressed out about work at all
I listen Howard I am I don't know you
are I'm on this show 24/7 you see what
if you could do more or less you see
when I answer emails I'm checking emails
all day long and on top of everything
first of all I just got the agenda for
or of the amount of meetings there's
five meetings this year but don't you
have to look up things look over things
yeah like there's your homework yeah
like when you're in Napa Valley
drinking wine I'll be looking why you
have to attack her we all have weekend's
no way to want to just kind of chill out
a little bit that's up to me don't you
what are you doing wasting your time
with photography don't you just want to
chill out that that to me is chilling
okay so this to me is chilling or two
recreation I just think you have too
much free time well that and I think you
have too much free time yeah but I'm
your boss I know I can have all the free
time I died I know but I don't hired you
so I'd have free time I should make him
so busy he doesn't get home till nine
o'clock at night and then he passes out
no I just do [ __ ] ah so annoying I lay
in bed thinking I go how does he have
all this free time always carrying on
does this sound like fun no on that
board you don't want to call her bored
because you're bored I'm not kidding
that's not fun I I came up with some
work for him to do though yeah yeah I
just thought of something last night
okay get ready Gary I got a big
assignment for you oh good since you're
looking for [ __ ] to do I love to
contribute okay well you're gonna
contribute something down for him to do
look up you know I love how Gary we have
a camera on Gary and like like he has
his eggs and he wants to get to him and
look I'm actually engaging him in
Congress
I'd like he kind of walks away and then
and like yeah they would because you
know what I'm waiting for you to say
something and then you're like not there
but I feel you checked out all right go
ahead and eat I'm gonna watch it no no
no no I have nothing to say go ahead I'm
gonna watch it's getting cold I want to
watch you I just like watching you eat
those eggs are battling those teeth and
those teeth are gonna win every time and
you know we're gonna be done with him
and then he can go eat breakfast for an
hour
no go ahead finish your breakfast what
do you think that big note is on Gary's
cave like what's that one with a white
page Robin and I'll play that where is
trying to keep him busy so his eggs go
call I'm keeping him working right now
all right
I feel bad now his breakfast is getting
cold
dang you can go eat your breakfast why
do you keep the eggs so far away from
either you have to swivel much because I
they are close but when I talk to you I
want to get close to the bike okay if I
swiveled and didn't move I'd be off Mike
and you'd be pissed because he was like
this no inclination at all today that
from 625 to now you'd be beating your
[ __ ] up
not my feet initiative
[Music]